good morning to you thanks for being
with us um i mean what more would you
want to see the government doing to deal
with this heatwave kit has laid out
there very clearly that there have been
lots of
things put in place to make sure that
services can cope as best as they can
well we think the government ought to do
a number of things first is to uh turn
up for work you your line of questioning
for kit malt house that
in that interview was very uncomfortable
because the prime minister is clearly
clocked off and so many of the ministers
in his government the second thing is
that we think there ought to be a
dedicated minister in the cabinet office
who coordinates an emergency response of
this
nature and the third is that we think
there ought to be a
concerted work from central government
to work with local areas to make sure
that local resilience plans are in place
we saw during the pandemic how many
local areas responded magnificently
rising up to sort out national problems
that couldn't be solved from the centre
but we do have a patchwork of those
emergency responses across the country
and we need some coordination to make
sure that every place has a local
resilience plan in place
to protect us from extreme heat events
like this
so just to be clear you want to see a
dedicated minister to deal with uh
resilience to natural disaster
that's right we've had a number of
national emergencies in recent years
but we're also seeing more extreme
weather events across the country many
parts of the country hit for example by
frequent flooding as well and when
temperatures rise to this level as many
of the scientists and experts have been
saying on your show there are serious
health repercussions not least for
people who are elderly but also for some
people who are extremely fit too so we
need to have a national coordinated
response and we think a dedicated
minister in the cabinet office would be
one way of making sure that this runs
right through the heart of government
and everything that they do
i mean i guess the government response
would say that they have the cobra
committee that deals with these
emergencies but
we'll leave that there for now i mean
specifically on on schools lisa and andy
do you think that they should be uh
closing as kids are having to deal with
some
incredible temperatures in the classroom
i mean i would follow the advice of the
scientists i'm not remotely qualified to
tell um children and teachers
and parents whether it's
um whether whether that advice is right
or not and i would trust the scientists
who say that schools are perfectly safe
as long as precautions are taken and my
own child has gone to school today with
armed with all the things that we've
been told some cream hats
water
schools across the country i know are
relaxing school uniform requirements to
make sure that children can stay cool
and they're following the advice that is
given keeping children out of direct
sunlight and on that basis i see no
reason to disregard the advice from
experts and to follow that advice
involved
i mean would a labour government lisa
nandy bring in uh
perhaps legislation or more um
guidelines proper guidelines that say
that you know i have some friends from
australia that say that when they were
at school no hat no place so they
couldn't go outside in the temperatures
when they were too high if they didn't
have a hat on do you think we should
have more rules like that seeing as the
met office say that these are going to
be
summers like this for the foreseeable
no i think schools take a very common
sense approach to this if a child turns
up without a hat they'll find they'll
find one in lost property or or find a
way to make sure that that child can can
be outside with their friends and stay
stay cool i think pragmatism and common
sense
and following the advice that he's given
is the best way to get through these
events but there's a bigger question as
well of course about why we're seeing
more frequent extreme weather events and
hotter temperatures
and action on climate change making sure
that we're leading the world again after
a lost decade in cutting back our
investment in clean energy seems to me
that's the thing that government ought
to be focusing on right now
so let's move on then to the
conservative leadership race and on that
very subject um you will have seen that
many of the the candidates say they're
going to scrap the net zero targets by
2050 i mean what's what's your response
to that idea
i mean just you know today of all days
it just shows the absurdity of the
leadership contest you've got a group of
candidates all of whom are very much
preoccupied with winning the votes of
conservative mps and 160 000
conservative party members and the
interests of the country have been
completely discarded not only are a
number of the candidates saying that
they want to scrap the commitment to net
zero but leveling up which was the big
idea the mandate on which this
government came to power in 2019 and
turning around the situation where most
people in most places have been written
off and the contribution that they can
make written off by their government for
lack of backing and investment that is
barely featured in the debate that is a
huge betrayal of millions of people who
voted for change and that's why i'm in
darlington today to set out labour's
plans to start putting us putting that
right getting the economy firing on all
cylinders and making sure that all
people in all places can make a
contribution again
well there were some reporting that
perhaps uh leveling up will be rebranded
but the mayor of t side said that rishi
sunak is is committed to it so that will
still continue there will still be this
plan under arishi united government if
he wins
i mean i i found it extraordinary that a
few weeks ago rishi cena was the
chancellor who was
declaring that we would level up the
country and now he's planning to run the
economy like thatcher
many people across the north of england
who will remember the way that our
economy was run under thatcher is the
opposite of what boris johnson and rishi
sunak promised they promised to bring
good jobs back to our community and get
money back into people's pockets and get
the economy firing on all cylinders
we're one of the most geographically
unequal countries in the world and most
parts of the country suffer from chronic
lack of investment that's why we've set
out plans to invest 28 billion a year
every year for a decade in bringing
those good clean energy jobs back to
britain we could tackle climate change
we could get money back into people's
pockets and we could get the economy
firing on all cylinders if we had a
government with ambition for this
country that matched the ambition of the
people in it
and at least nandy you will have seen in
the debate from friday from some of the
coverage over the weekend from the
debate last night that uh the word
socialist is being bandied about is
being used as a stick to beat a number
of the candidates list trust has been
described as socialists rishi soon as
being described as socialist why is that
such a dirty word for the conservative
party
i mean because they this is the most
extreme version of the conservative
party
i've ever seen and because they believe
that only individuals can achieve things
that by working together we do worse and
in that they're completely wrong look at
the recent strikes track action over
public sector pay in wales the welsh
labor government avoided strike action
because with their workforce and they
work with employers as partners that's
one of the reasons why i'm here in
darlington today to set out labour's
plans to work with communities to give
them more powers to be able to generate
revenue and invest it in the things that
matter to them saving local buildings
and high streets and reinvesting in the
people in places that have been
completely written off by this
government we've got a really extreme
contest playing out across the tory
party at the moment and the people have
been cut out of the conversation labour
are determined that we're going to bring
people back into the conversation and
partner with them in order to change
this country for the good
okay lisa nandy shadow leveling up
secretary thank you very much for your
time this morning thank you for being
with us thank you